[Applaus]
[Musik]
die vom krieg mit putin russland
geschundene ukraine pflegt und
internationale hilfe einer ära bieten
ist die umgehende aufnahme des
osteuropäischen landes in die
europäische union die mitglieder und
institutionen der eu signalisierte
sofort ihre solidarität mit den
bedrohten land zeigten sich auch das
wohl bereit in den kandidatenstatus zu
gewähren verwiesen jedoch auf den langen
prozess den eine vollständige aufnahme
erfordere denn ein beitritt zur eu ist
in der tat eine sehr komplexe
angelegenheit politisch rechtlich und
vor allem wirtschaftlich schließlich
sind damit riesige geldströmen
verbundenen vor allem wenn es um arme
neumitglieder geht die durch
subventionen aufgepäppelt werden müssen
wenn dies alles nicht ordentlich gemacht
wird und schief geht wird die rechnung
nicht nur für die altmitglieder teuer
auch das neue land kann dadurch noch
tiefer in die bredouille rutschen die
gelder stärken dann nur noch mehr
korrupte mafiastrukturen sie kommen bei
den normalen menschen nicht in form
höherer einkommen an und diese wandern
freizügigkeit in die reicheren eu
staaten ab eine abwärtsspirale wurde in
gang gesetzt und daher müssen wir uns in
diesem video die dringende frage stellen
wie fit könnte die ukraine überhaupt für
einen eu beitritt sein kann die
ukrainische wirtschaft die russische
invasion überhaupt überleben oder anders
ausgedrückt wie könnte sich die
russische invasion auf die ukraine
auswirken die in den besetzten gebieten
leben würden werden sie in der lage sein
ihre unternehmen und geschäfte
weiterzuführen oder werden sich von der
hand in den mund leben müssen putin
begnügte sich nicht mit dem einmarsch in
die ost ukraine und startete seine
invasion in allen teilen des landes der
kreml erwartete einen zweiten august
1968 als der prager frühling durch eine
blitz invasion niedergeschlagen wurde
oder vielleicht auch so etwas wie seine
fünftägigen siegreichen georgien
feldzugs aber auch dies hat nicht
geklappt
[Musik]
jetzt droht keys eine wiederholung der
schrecken von grosny und russland ein
zweites afghanistan
die russen sind in genau das
hineingelaufen was aus ihrer eigenen
geschichte so gut kennen einen großen
vaterländischen krieg nur dass ihre
rolle jetzt dieselbe ist wie die des
damaligen nazideutschland und in die
rolle der sowjetunion sind jetzt die
taxlerin ukraine geschlüpft wie die
dinge letztendlich ausgehen werden weiß
niemand sogar wir hier bei dieser wahl
politik verfügen über keine
kristallkugel aber wir haben etwas
anderes ein langes gedächtnis denn ja
meine lieben zuschauer es gibt einen
präsident fall welcher der ukraine sehr
ähnlich ist ein land das ebenfalls grund
putin überfallen wurde und von welchen
dann sprechen wir ganz genau georgien
ein kleines land im kaukasus dessen
hauptstadt tiflis heißt
[Musik]
sind die ukraine und georgien absolut
ähnlich nein aber man kann nicht leugnen
dass es eine menge parallelen gibt aus
denen der eine menge lehren ziehen
können falls du ein digitaler nomade
bist oder jemand der sich wird diesen
lebensstil interessiert hast du bestimmt
schon mal was von diesem land gehört
es ist eines der angesagtesten ziele für
aktiv will acer und digitale nomaden
tatsächlich ist georgien eines der
interessantesten länder der welt und das
hat es vor allem diesen einen mann zu
verdanken
darf ich vorstellen
der ehemalige präsident von georgien
michail saakaschwili wenn dieser mann in
san francisco geboren worden wäre gäbe
es mindestens schon drei netflix serien
über sein leben er gehört einer winzigen
gruppe jener politiker an die sich
rühmen können gleich in zwei
verschiedenen ländern politische
spitzenämter bekleidet zu haben in
georgien und auf welches dann würdest du
tippen
31 richtig die ukraine nachdem er mit
dem regieren in georgien tätig war
erhielt saga spielt die ukrainische
staatsbürgerschaft und wurde über nur
der region odessa absolut alles im leben
dieses mal ist es absolut filmreif egal
ob man ihn mag oder licht niemand kann
leugnen dass er eine einzigartige person
der zeitgeschichte ist ein mann der
leidenschaft und fast zugleich erregt
und wer ist sein größter hater dreimal
dazu raten wladimir putin und was auch
wenn wir sprechen hier wirklich von
echtem tiefem hass auf das hier ist ein
direktes zitat eines tages werde ich
saakaschwili an den eiern aufhängen
wladimir putin im jahr 2008 auf eier
wenn eine putin mit sowas droht dann
sollte sondern schon ein wenig angst
haben nicht jedoch saakaschwili denn der
hat wohl nicht nur einfacher aus stapel
seine hohen sind bestimmt auch so was
wie kryptonite für putin wie auch immer
so was heißt putin ist vielleicht aber
warum der ganze hass werdet ihr euch
fragen und die wahrheit ist dass ein
fünftel des georgischen stadtgebiet von
russland besetzt ist und zwar seit 2008
als der georgien krieg ausbrach das
stimmt man könnte sagen dass georgien
eine mini version der ukraine
die frage lautet also warum entscheiden
sich so viele digitale nomaden sein
leben in einem durch russland bedrohten
und überfallenen land hat georgien die
russische invasion überlebt welche
lehren können die ukraine aus dieser
geschichte ziehen welche fehler hat
georgien gemacht und was haben sie
richtig gemacht heute werden wir all
diese fragen beantworten aber zuerst
wollen wir uns hierzu ein wenig mit der
überaus interessanten historie des
kleinen jedoch unglaublich geschütz
trächtigen landes befassen
[Musik]
oberstdorf
wie ich bereits erwähnt habe georgien
ist ein magnet für digitale nomaden
georgien ist immer noch ein armes land
und plante ursprünglich einen formellen
antrag auf eu mitgliedschaft im jahr
2025 zu stellen um in den 2030er jahren
der union beizutreten aufgrund des
russischen überfalls auf die ukraine
reichte das land den antrag jedoch
bereits am dritten märz 2022 ein das ist
schon eine kometenhafte entwicklung vor
allem wenn man bedenkt dass georgien vor
20 jahren noch wie soll ich ausdrücken
also jetzt schon bestimmt borat gesicht
war nun im vergleich zu den meisten
orten im damaligen georgien drückte
poggersdorf wie singapur
[Musik]
in diesem land kristallisierten sich all
die stereotype heraus die euch
vielleicht über eine ehemalige vw
dritten blick im kopf herumschwirren
unterwelt wand und korruption und armut
nicht dass wir uns falsch verstehen
georgien ist eine alte kulturnation die
fest in der geschichte des abendlandes
verankert ist es war nach armin eines
der ersten länder die das christentum
als staatsreligion einführte und zwar
schon im jahr
337 nach christus also fast 50 jahre vor
dem römischen reich selbst während
seines glorreichen goldenen zeitalters
zwischen dem elften und 13 jahrhundert
wurde georgien die stärkste macht in
transkaukasien welcher erst durch die
invasion dämmung holen gebrochen wurde
im 18 jahrhundert schloss ist einen
schutzvertrag mit russland um sich vom
osmanischen einfluss abzugrenzen und
schwuppdiwupp keine 20 jahre nach diesen
schutzvertrag drohte der russische zar
per dekret das georgische königshaus und
annektierte den osten des landes
natürlich wird absichtlich sich die
ganze region zu erobern aber russland
brauchte noch weitere 54 jahre um den
widerstand in west georgiens verbrechen
und die vollständige kontrolle über das
ganze land zu erlangen die schon damals
beliebte strategie russlands teile und
herrsche georgier gegen boston gegen ab
rasen eine tradition die sich der kreml
bis heute bewahrt hat obwohl eigentlich
vereins der kreml jetzt mehr als das er
spaltet nicht wahr aber wie auch immer
während des kalten krieges war georgien
eine republik innerhalb der sowjetunion
im jahr 1991 erklettern das land seine
unabhängigkeit und zog in den krieg
gegen moskau ähnlich wie in der ukraine
gibt es in georgien zwei provinzen deren
bevölkerung sich eher russisch
ukrainisch fühlt die rede ist von
südossetien und abchasien seit 1992
gehören sie zu jenen regionen die auf
landkarten durch kleine linien
schraffiert sind und was geschah im rest
des landes nun um ehrlich zu sein nichts
gutes viele von euch würden denken dass
das ende des kommunismus eine gute
nachricht für alle bewohner der
ehemaligen udssr war georgien ist jedoch
eine der ausnahmen von dieser regel um
euch eine vorstellung zu geben in nur
zehn jahren ist damals das bip georgiens
auf weniger als die hälfte eingebrochen
darüber hinaus leidet das land weiterhin
unter einem starken bevölkerungsrückgang
im jahr 1989 hat der georgier 5.000.000
1 jetzt sind es noch 3,7 millionen
menschen und ihr fragt euch vielleicht
wie die dinge an diesen ort so schief
laufen konnten nun überlegt mal in den
1990 er jahren wurde georgien zu
perfekten nährboden für das organisierte
verbrechen und korrupte politiker aber
das ist noch nicht alles das bisschen
industrie das ist im land gab kam aus
moskau als georgien unabhängig wurde
wurden alle fabriken geschlossen in den
1990 er jahren war der wichtigste
georgische exportartikel der von den
sowjets in den eisen und stahlwerten
zurückgelassene metallschrott genau so
sah es aus das haupt exportgut georgiens
war der metallschrott der von dem gerade
geschlossenen fabriken übrig geblieben
war an dieser tatsache kann man sich
vorstellen wie es in dem land aus
andererseits ist das ganze halt auch
nicht gerade so megamäßig überraschen
denn wir sprechen über den kaukasus alle
länder und regionen dort haben ein
ähnliches oder noch viel größeres wir
sind schon ausdrücken würde mit hohem
potenzial entschuldigt bitte meine
ausdrucksweise ich zitiere ja nur einen
us präsidenten bei mir gerade kein
passendes goethe zitat zum kaukasus ein
feld aber der hätte es wohl auch nicht
besser sagen können wir sprechen von
einer region in der aserbaidschan
armenien und tschetschenien liegt eine
der finstersten und am meisten
geschundenen gegenden des planeten doch
im jahr 2003 änderte sich das schicksal
georgiens für immer und welches
umwälzende ereignis spielte sich damals
ab aufgepasst
[Musik]
die rosenrevolution
es gibt momente in der geschichte in
denen eine person alles verändern kann
und hier haben wir es mit einem dieser
historischen augenblicke zu tun die
betreffende person ist michael
saakaschwili und einige werden sagen
dass dieses video nicht mehr ist als
eine lobeshymne auf diesen mann aber
egal welche meinung man über ihn haben
markt kann niemand leugnen dass ein
absoluter tausendsassa ist der in seinem
leben schon alles gesehen und erlebt hat
ganz objektiv betrachtet hat diese alte
mann die geschichte seines landes fast
im alleingang vollkommen verändert und
ich meine es ernst auf bis zu alt
politik haben wir viele länder und
politische persönlichkeit analysiert
aber saakaschwilis biografie könnte als
vorlage für einen neuen monumental
schicken wie doktor schiwago dienen
daher können wir in unserem heutigen
bescheidenen video nur einen kleinen
ausschnitt davon behandeln aber dieser
ausschnitt hat es in sich damals im jahr
2003 war michael sucker spiel einen
rechtsanwalt den vereinigten staaten
studiert hatte dort wurde aus ihm eine
große verfechter des westens und des
freien marktes oja meiner lieben
libertären freunde die diesen kanal
verfolgen wenn es einen helden gibt der
eure ideale eines minimalen staatswesens
und lieber tourismus repräsentiert dann
ist es kein anderer als saakaschwili
im jahr 2003 führte er das an was die
als die erfolgreichste libertärer
revolution letzten 100 jahre bezeichnen
könnten die rosenrevolution ok alles
müssen wir zugeben die art und weise wie
an die macht kam war nicht die
demokratisch der welt aber vergessen
wenn ich dass georgien so etwas wie das
dorf und borat war nur noch schlimmer
auf jeden fall kam saakaschwili mit
einem ganz bestimmten versprechen an die
macht klar wie ein paradies der freien
marktwirtschaft zu verwandeln das
bedeutete korruptionsbekämpfung niedrige
steuern und freihandelsabkommen mit
ganzen welt um euch eine vorstellung
davon zu geben seine reformen waren so
radikal dass sie sogar vom
internationalen währungsfonds der
kapitalistischen propaganda der
westlichen welt ordnung zu weit gingen
und dieser dem land kein geld dafür
leihen wollte fährt selbst der iwf
dachte dass hacker spiel island bei so
niedrigen steuersätzen einfach nicht in
der lage sein würde seine kredite
zurückzuzahlen aber ratet mal was
schließlich passiert ist was meint ihr
schaut euch einfach dieses diagramm an
[Musik]
habt ihr es georgien hat eines der
minimalistischen steuersysteme der welt
ist erfolgt ein modell das fast
identisch ist mit dem estland und wenn
wieder etwas zeit für normale videos
sein sollte werden wir auch darüber ein
schönes video dreht also aber nicht
vergessen falls auch ihr daran
interessiert seid von den erfolgen
anderer länder zu lernen das
steuersystem war aber nicht der einzige
trumpf saakaschwilis hinzu kamen
freihandelsabkommen und die drastische
konsolidierung des aufgeblähten
staatsapparat um euch eine vorstellung
zu geben saakaschwili hat in den ersten
jahren seiner amtszeit sogar mehr als
16.000 korrupte polizisten entlassen und
ich weiß ganz genau was er denkt das
ganze klingt wie der feuchte traum
einiger visual politik redakteure nicht
wahr und ja so ist es natürlich wird es
viele von euch wie ein schreckliches
neoliberales albtraum regierungsprogramm
kriegen aber die wahrheit ist nunmal
dass die daten für sich selbst sprechen
[Musik]
zwischen 2004 und 2007 wuchs das bip
georgiens um sagenhafte 35 prozent und
internationale investitionen strömten
ins land ok ich muss zugeben dass ich
hier bei nicht ganz objektiv sein kann
denn auch ferrero der hersteller meiner
haupt suchtmittel nutella und mon chéri
hat im jahr 2007 eine anlage zur
verarbeitung von haselnüssen in georgien
eröffnet denn eines der haupt
exportgüter der orgel sind nüsse nüsse
und wein georgien ist bekannt als die
wiege des weins innerhalb weniger jahre
exportierte dieses land also haselnüssen
und wein als gäbe es kein morgen und ich
weiß was ich jetzt denkt das ist der
primäre sektor georgiens wo bleibt die
industrie ja ihr habt natürlich recht
aber bedenkt bitte dass georgien
ursprünglich die borers dort ausgesehen
hat das wichtigste war dass das land auf
dem richtigen weg war es war das star
des kaukasus tja sodann dann kam bis zur
katastrophe
gut ins erste opfer
ein weiteres versprechen dass das spiel
bei seinem amtsantritt gab war die
nationale wiedervereinigung die georgier
waren alles andere als glücklich darüber
dass zwei im grunde unabhängige
provinzen existierten es mag etwas
seltsam klingen aber obwohl georgien ein
so kleines land mit weniger als vier
millionen einwohnern ist gibt es mehrere
verschiedenartige strafen und ethnien
und es gibt zwei regionen in denen
georgisch nicht einmal erwünscht ist süd
ossetien und abchasien
und was haben diese regionen gemeinden
nun abgesehen davon dass sie keine große
bindung zu georgien haben haben sie eine
große zuneigung zur mütterchen russland
so sieht's aus diese geschichte ist für
euch sicher ein großes special sie ist
fast identisch mit der im donbass oder
auch der krim aber nicht nur das wir
euch vorstellen könnt ist sehr schwer
seine liebe zum freien markt und den
westen zu offenbaren ohne das
eifersüchtige russland zu verärgern vor
allem als saakaschwili sein
ausdrückliches interesse an einem
nato-beitritt erklärte wie im falle der
ukraine erfolgte putins erste angriff
auf die portemonnaies der georgier im
jahr 2006 forderte russland einen
handelsboykott gegen georgien an und was
folgte auf die portemonnaie attacke ganz
genau der militärschlag
russland und georgien streiten um eine
abtrünnige region das ist richtig im
jahr 2008 bombardierte eine gruppe
südossetische separatisten eine gruppe
georgischer soldaten georgien hatte
versucht eine territoriale lösung
auszuhandeln die es den rebellen
regionen ermöglichen würde eine weitere
zu georgien zuzustimmen aber die
verhandlungen scheiterten und dieser
angriff war der tropfen der das fass zum
überlaufen brachte zuerst marschierte
die georgische armee in süd ossetien an
dann erklärte russland seine
unterstützung fürs musizieren so kann es
zu einem krieg zwischen russland und
georgien
wie im fall der ukraine erreichte
russland auch die hauptstadt georgiens
genau wie in kiew bombardierten die
russen auch die flughafen von tiflis nur
zwölf tagen besetzt russlands fast das
gesamte land einschließlich jener teile
der bevölkerung anti russisch
eingestellt haben also ungefähr genauso
wie in der ukraine mit einem
entscheidende unterschied die georgier
waren in einer viel schwächeren
situation überlegt mal die ukrainische
armee habe fast acht jahre zeit sich auf
eine invasion vorzubereiten darüber
haben wir schon in vielen anderen
personalpolitik videos gesprochen
georgien ist jedoch ein viel kleineres
landen in einer viel kleineren
bevölkerung und armee so dass es
letztlich leichter zu erobern ist eine
invasion der gesamten ukraine würde viel
länger als fünf oder zwölf tage dauern
aber was ist am ende in georgien
passiert
nun in diesem fall vermittelte
frankreich um einen waffenstillstand
auszuhandeln
russland bekam was es wollte die
kontrolle über abchasien und südossetien
im gegenzug zogen sie ihre truppen aus
dem übrigen georgien ab und wie sieht
die lage heute in georgien aus nun wenn
man sich verschiedene landkarten ansieht
erkennt man schnell auf den russischen
welt karten sind ab da sie und
südossetiens zwei unabhängige republiken
kein anderes land erkennt sie jedoch als
solche an auf den weltkarten die im rest
der welt herausgegeben werden sind sie
als zwei gestrichelte gebiete
dargestellt in der praxis verhalten sich
diese beiden republiken jedoch die zwei
russische provinzen sie verwendeten
sogar den rubel als gesetzliches
zahlungsmittel im grunde ist es also
genauso wie in donetsk und lohans über
die wir bereits ein video gemacht haben
dass ich euch natürlich verlinken werden
und glaubt mir er würde es nicht in
diesen republiken leben wollen die frage
ist jedoch was im übrigen georgien
passiert ist ob die menschen trotz des
krieges mit russland ihr leben
weiterführen können nun genau das werden
wir jetzt genauer unter die lupe nehmen
[Musik]
zwischen russland und dem westen
im jahr 2013 verlorener spiele die
wahlen und wer sollte wohl sein
nachfolger werden nun passt jetzt gut
auf denn dieser geschichte tummeln sich
noch jede menge anderer bunter
charaktere aus drei spielen sein
nachfolger war diese hätten ihr jetzt
auf dem bildschirm sehen
die rede ist von bettina iwanischwili
auch bekannt unter dem spitznamen und
boris dieser nette herr hat in den
neunziger jahren mit dem verkauf von
computern in russland ein hübsches
vermögen gemacht und wie groß war sein
vermögen werdet ihr euch fragen nun mal
schätzt dass dieser mann über eine
geldsumme verfügte die einem drittel des
gesamten
bruttoinlandsprodukts georgiens
entspricht ja das ist richtig und
nachdem er in russland so viel geld
verdient hatte kehrte er in seine heimat
georgien zurück um sein glück in der
politik zu suchen im jahr 2012 gründete
er seine eigene partei nannte sie george
in dream also trauben georgiens und
pumpte ordentlich geld in sich hinein
und wie ihr euch vorstellen können hat
die partei george in dream mit der
aktuellen wahlkampf kosten die wahl im
folgenden jahr gewonnen doch damit nicht
genug nach seiner wahlniederlage wurde
saakaschwili in exil geschickt und
verlor sogar seine staatsbürgerschaft
in den berg saakaschwili ist eines der
wenigen beispiele für eine person die
technisch gesehen starten losgeworden
ist das heißt er hatte einige jahre lang
überhaupt keine staatsangehörigkeit aber
das ist eine andere geschichte für ein
ganz eigenes video auf jeden fall
dominiert war nicht willig parteiseite
2013 die georgische politik und welche
ideologie hängt diese partei an nun wie
ihr euch vorstellen könnte ist die
deutschen die partei so puristisch wie
eine partei in georgien nur sein kann
das heißt eigentlich gar nicht wie zu
erwarten haben die meisten georgier null
bock auf die russen sie wollen nicht
dass russland auch nur die geringste
präsenz in ihrem land zeigt es ist
schließlich das land mit denen sie sich
praktisch immer noch im krieg befinden
weil es schwierig ist jedoch prorussisch
genug um so etwas durchzuziehen russland
will die einfuhr von georgischen wein
und wasser wieder aufnehmen aber täuscht
euch nicht georgien ist noch weit davon
entfernt zur russischen einflusssphäre
zu gehör ja es stimmt seit 2030 hat
georgien den handel mit russland wieder
aufgenommen aber es ist nicht sein
einziger handelspartner die europäische
union unterzeichnet ein
freihandelsabkommen mit georgien so
sieht's aus georgien treibt sowohl mit
russland als auch mit der europäischen
union handeln und dies erklärt nicht nur
den aufschwung seiner weine deren export
immer weiter wächst es erklärt auch die
entstehung eines neuen
wirtschaftssektors denn er vor wenigen
jahrzehnten in diesem land undenkbar war
tourismus
und ich weiß was ihr denkt tourismus wer
würde schon gerne in einem land urlaub
machen das einst wie borat dorf aussah
ohne so berühmt zu sein und dass ich
darüber hinaus auch noch im krieg
befindet nun schaut euch einfach mal
diese grafik an
die wahrheit ist dass georgien vor der
pandemie fast acht millionen besucher
pro jahr hatte diese wachstumszahlen
sind fast ein wunder ja es stimmt zwar
dass es in den besetzten gebieten
gefährlich ist in der schwarzmeerstadt
batumi jedoch sind hotels aus dem boden
geschossen wie pilze nach einem warmen
regen viele davon mit ausländischem
kapital finanziert georgien ist zu einem
relativ preiswerten reiseziele russische
und türkische touristen geworden doch es
ist nicht alles gold was glänzt ja es
ist wahr georgien geht es heute viel
besser als noch vor 20 jahren allerdings
hat das land viele produktive einwohner
verloren und hat immer noch eine
arbeitslosenquote von 17 prozent
[Musik]
in den letzten zehn jahren wurde kaum in
die bildung investiere in folge dessen
ist es für unternehmen mit hoher
wertschöpfung schwierig sich zu
etablieren es gibt keine gut
ausgebildeten arbeitskräfte dann zu
schweigen davon dass das system
zunehmend autoritär wird im jahr 2021
wurde saakaschwili aus ziemlich coolen
gründen ins gefängnis geworfen und
russland drängt immer noch darauf
georgien wieder in sein einfluss lehre
zu bringen was ist jedoch nicht
geschafft hat die wirtschaftliche
entwicklung des kleinen landes dauerhaft
zu sabotieren noch ist also schwer
vorstellbar dass das land kurzfristig
mitglied der europäischen union oder der
nato während hat aber es konnte sich
eine eigene existenz und eine
aufstrebende zukunftsperspektive
aufbauen trotz seines großen
missliebigen nachbarn
[Musik]
und eines ist auch sicher aus georgien
kann man viele lehren ziehen die frage
lautet was kann die ukraine von georgien
lernen ist es möglich dass der westliche
teil der ukraine eine vorbildliche
modell ökonomie wird die investition
ansieht könnten in der ukraine
innovative industrien entstehen selbst
wenn sich das land in einem kalten krieg
mit russland befinde wäre eine eu
aufnahme unter diesen umständen möglich
welche risiken und chancen würde diese
bergen für die ukraine und die eu selbst
aber all das sind themen für unser
nächstes video über die ukraine und die
eu wir würden euch jedoch gerne in
dessen ausarbeitung einbeziehen daher
könnt ihr euch jetzt schon gerne im
kommentarbereich mit diesen ihr
aufgeworfenen fragen beschäftigen und
eure eigenen ideen zu eindringen bin
gespannt was dabei herauskommt ich hoffe
also dass euch dieses video gefallen hat
falls ja gibt uns bitte einen leichten
und freunden und vergesst nicht dass awo
mit glöckchen und keines unserer videos
dazu verpassen natürlich freuen wir uns
auch jederzeit über eine kleine spende
von euch mit der jurist hält dieses
projekt weiterzuführen den paypal link
dazu findet ihr in der beschreibung
unter diesem video was gut und bis bald
[Musik]